bonsoir à tous comme chaque semaine
france info et l'ina vous offre un
voyage dans le temps à travers les
archives de la télévision pour mieux
comprendre l'actualité contemporaine
vous regardez l'inattendu et vous êtes
les bienvenus là monsieur bonsoir je
voudrais regarder la france au fond des
yeux
j'aimerais beaucoup que j'aime un train
de tricoter d'accord là-dessus à votre
place je la ramène à un peu moins mais
si vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il
vous manque qu'une seule chose que tout
petit détail de ce qui lui arrive est
valable à mes côtés tariq ali et
ludivine lovet journaliste à la
rédaction de l'ina bonjour à tous les
deux vous avez sélectionné des sujets
d'archivés qui trouve un écho
particulier avec notre actualitté tahri
conviens avec vous sur le malaise de la
police alors que les syndicats de la
profession doivent être reçus au
ministère de l'intérieur et voilà ils
vont être reçus au ministère de
l'intérieur par gérald darmanin pour
expliquer leur ras-le-bol à ce sujet -
ya un point qui m'a interpellé c'est le
manque de moyens pourquoi parce qu'on en
parle depuis des décennies on va voir un
exemple en 1975 avec l'interview d'un
syndicaliste
les raisons tiennent essentiellement aux
moyens et aux conditions de travail
il faut savoir que au plan des véhicules
par exemple qui sont absolument
indispensables à l'accomplissement de
nos missions
et bien alors qu'il nous faudrait un
véhicule pour 5 ce qui me paraît
raisonnable dans les grands services à
paris la police judiciaire les brigades
territoriales comme dans les sûretés
urbaines en province et à peu près un
véhicule pour 15 nous n'avons pas de
matériel radio quand on songe que à
l'office central de répression du
banditisme qui est pourtant d'après les
augures
un service pilote en matière de matériel
il n'y a pas un seul poste de radio
portable
les inspecteurs de police dispose à peu
près d'une machine à écrire pour trois
ans qui fait qu' il doit s'attendre que
là est fini pour taper leur rapport ce
manque de moyens la sq ont entendu
c'était en 1975 à 45 ans et on entend
aujourd'hui dans les débats exactement
la même chose un mot d'amour tournée la
semaine dernière autres sujets ludivine
le retour d'un magazine culte
c'était le magazine star des cours de
récré dans les années 70 80
après plusieurs tentatives de reprises
ces dernières années une nouvelle
formule trimestriels pif le mag sort ce
mercredi dans les kiosques les gadgets
seront bien sûr au rendez vous plus
écolo plus respectueux de la
biodiversité
d'ailleurs ces objets ont marqué
l'histoire du magazine il y en a eu des
mythiques comme les pois sauteurs
je les ai retrouvés dans cette archive
de 1971 souvent le gadget est un jouet
et nous avons cru remarquer que ceux qui
font vendre chaque semaine un journal de
jeunes sont très souvent d'inspiration
scientifique autre conquête des sciences
naturelles au service du cac jette ses
pois sauteurs qui s'agitent sans fin
comme mû par une force magique
en fait ce ne sont que de petites
prisons à l'intérieur desquelles ce
débat une chenille vous vous demandez
combien vous avez vu un poster dix
millions dix millions dix millions de
fois sauveur enfin nous en avons utilisé
5 millions environ et nous avons les 5
millions ici pour d autres émotions qui
sautent dans laquelle mais c'est marrant
parce que je me souviens de d'un cadeau
de piles gadgets c'était justement les
prestateurs vous avez voilà en tout cas
cette époque puis des jets et c'est ces
gadgets justement pif et ses gadgets
était vendu à plus d'un million
d'exemplaires chaque semaine voilà pour
l'actualité de cette semaine mais que
s'est il passé le 16 décembre
ces dernières années vous regardez le
zapping de l'ina ça s'est passé à 16
décembre justement
bonjour le sommet fortis car s'achève
aujourd'hui à la martinique et les deux
chefs d'état auraient trouvé un
compromis sur les futures négociations
avec les producteurs de pétrole
cergy doit être à l'une des cinq villes
nouvelles qui vont encadrer la capitale
pour dit on la sauve et de l'étouffement
et de la paralysie tête de pont la
préfecture constructions futuristes
mariage béton verre acier
[Musique]
aux quatre coins de l'hexagone c'est la
même déferlante dans les salles obscures
la force est bien visible 500 1000
réservations en france du jamais vu
c'est un privilège peut-être d'avoir
fait quatre films que j'avais envie de
faire
j'ai empêché personne de tourner je ne
gêne pas le cinéma qui a dit en vouloir
parce que je fais un peu ce que je veux
les chansons d'amour par exemple été les
choses auxquelles je ne pouvais pas
toucher parce que c'était les chansons
d'amour écrites par des hommes et ce
n'était pas comme ça que j'avais envie
de parler d'amour
[Musique]
ma plus belle histoire d'amour fou au
soir ya demain
on va parler jouer à présent ça tombe
bien c'est de saison plus précisément on
va s'intéresser aux jouets genre et
poupées pour les filles voiture pour les
garçons ludivine ces clichés ont la vie
dure et le gouvernement tentent d'en
venir à bout depuis déjà quelques années
depuis particulièrement l'année dernière
en septembre 2019 les pouvoirs publics
et les professionnels du secteur signer
une charte pour la représentation mixte
des jouets une initiative renouvelée
cette année car en la matière les
stéréotypes sont bien ancrées dans la
société
et vous vous en doutez dans les archives
et bien à elle ça se représente très
bien les archives sont assez savoureuse
sur le sujet celle qui va suivre date de
1958 nous sommes en période de noël dans
un magazine féminin copie fidèle d'une
vraie chaise de bébé en jouant et sans
le savoir ghislaine pente ainsi
l'habitude de l'hygiène du confort d'un
matériel moderne de puériculture voilà
comment en 1958 ghislaine apprenez à
être une bonne maman grâce à sa poupée
et du côté des garçons et bien michel et
ses copains apprenez à eux à devenir de
grands ingénieurs grâce alors je la
construction mais surtout ce qui est
drôle c'est que sort noir et blanc on
imagine que c'est déjà rose pour les
fibres pour les girls mais balla vous
allez voir venir de grands ingénieurs
avec ce qui ma super ex l'électronique à
la portée des plus jeunes
ces garçons moins de 10 ans et avec ses
plans facile à lire ils peuvent faire
cinq montage différent de récepteurs
mais aussi des metteurs attend istor
bien sûr des garçons bricoleur face à
des filles bonne ménagère bien
évidemment j'imagine que ces stéréotypes
à l'époque était largement admis plus
que ça ils étaient même assumé par
certains professionnels du secteur les
rayons dédiés aux garçons étaient
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs bien garnie de
jouer et de figurines de guerre la
panoplie du bon bagarreur et même plus
le début de la virilité
d'après ce responsable de magasin en
1976 chez les garçons je pense qu'il ya
une
une virilité naissante qui fait que ce
garçon a besoin de de combattre c'est un
petit peu la musculature modèle que
chaque garçon de 12 13 ans voudrait
savoir quand il sera un peu plus vieux
cette musculature modèle avoué le tariq
nathanaël vous rêviez aussi dans un
peut-être un peu comme quand vous êtes
presque en tout cas cette douce est une
interview qu'on vient de voir était
diffusée à l'époque sur fr3 dans un
documentaire qui traitait justement de
la question du conditionnement des
enfants par le jouet c'était donc déjà
un sujet dans les années 70 et pour
l'illustrer des journalistes allaient
dans une école en région parisienne
tiens tu me donnes le pollen je te donne
la coupe et un boisement une fille non
tu la veux pas me lever toi oui toi tu
n'as donc je vous l'avais bien du côté
des enfants la distinction fille garçon
était bien intégrée et moi je voulais
ressembler habite du mois la cible elle
est jouée selon le genre quelles
conséquences cela peut-il avoir bien sûr
sur la vie des enfants concernés mais
plus globalement sur notre société bien
les scientifiques se posent la question
depuis quelques années maintenant et
récemment en 2015
une psychologue jamie jerou faisait ce
constat dressé ce constat
selon elle les adultes auraient plutôt
tendance à confier des jeux de
construction au garçon plutôt qu'aux
filles et cela expliquerait en partie la
sous représentation à des femmes dans la
science et la technologie
cette responsabilité des adultes étaient
déjà pointés du doigt dans le passé
écoutez cet éducateur nous sommes en
1978 du projet toujours ses propres
idées c'est trop tôt idéologie ses
propres pensées culturel d'en jouer
en fait quand on a essayé de laisser
jouer librement des garçons et des
filles on ne constate pas de différence
le débat sur les minarets va perdurer
dans le temps en 2004 dans un reportage
france 3 le constat de cette spécialiste
du jouet était plutôt amer les garçons
n'ont absolument pas le droit et n'ont
toujours pas le droit de jouer avec des
poupées cia une poupée pour la petite
soeur il a le droit de jouer avec
mais on n'achète pas tout
petit garçon parce que derrière il ya
cette crainte exprimée de
l'homosexualité masculine
ludivine les enseignes de jouets ont
quand même fait des efforts pour gommer
ces clichés dont on parle notamment dans
les rayons c'est vrai en 2020 les rayons
estampillé fille ou garçon ont tendance
à disparaître des magasins du côté des
jouets ils sont aussi de plus en plus
mixte même si les couleurs bleu et rose
ont tendance à perdurer règne toujours
dans les rayons à présent garçons et
filles jouent ensemble
contrairement aux années 50 il s'occupe
à deux de leurs poupées ils font le
ménage
il faut aussi du bricolage en tout cas
quoi qu'il arrive en 2020 des genres est
le jouet c'est le bon filon marketing
voilà les joyeux noël à vous si natal
[Musique]
voilà maintenant que les cadeaux sont
déballés on va passer à table avec l'un
des plus grands chefs français jean
françois piège deux étoiles au guide
michelin
bonsoir hauteur du grand livre de la
cuisine française recettes bourgeoise
est populaire chez hachette jédir bon et
gros il n' ya pas de problème il ya de
la recette
d'abord j'aimerais j'aimerais qu'on
avant de s'intéresser aux repas noël
j'aimerais qu'on parle de votre
actualité enfin de l'actualité en
général la situation sanitaire qui vous
contraint à fermer depuis maintenant
plusieurs plusieurs semaines plusieurs
mois ce week end
vous avez manifesté avec d'autres
professionnels c'est quoi votre message
message et qu'aujourd'hui on nous a
privé notre liberté d'entreprendre pour
des raisons sanitaires auxquels
évidemment on en convient et on laisse
le gouvernement gérait maintenant on ne
peut pas nous laisser assumer nous les
frais de cette fermeture
si on nous prive de notre liberté
d'entreprendre et le compte y est pas
aujourd'hui on a besoin d'avoir une
indemnisation au niveau 2 au niveau de
nos frais aujourd'hui on décaisse tous
les mois donc tous les mois parce que
une entreprise ferme et s'ils n'entrent
pas ce qui coûte et les indemnisations
sont pas à la hauteur de celles qui sont
là et puis le grand les grands absents
c'est les assureurs les assureurs
auxquels on a souscrit des contrats
d'assurance comme axa ne sont pas au
rendez vous donc ça fait une lourde
charge et on espère que le gouvernement
va nous entendre et sera à la hauteur de
ski
c'est à dire que si vous avez
l'autorisation de rouvrir le 20 janvier
comme c'est prévu pour l'instant vous
pourriez ne pas rouvrir pour des
questions d'argent
je pense qu'il ya une grande partie des
restaurateurs qui ne vont pas réouvrir
parce que le temps de fermeture est trop
grand et on a fait des quais c'est que
tous les mois et un moment donné faut
payer alors cette situation vous a
obligés à repenser votre manière de
travailler est ce qu'on peut se
réinventer tout en respectant et en
respectant la tradition de noël là
beaucoup de traditions à noël c'est quoi
pour vous la recette incontournable moi
noël j'allais dire si ya pas de foie
gras c'est pas noël j'aime bien j'aime
bien foie gras noël on en mange pas tous
les jours et j'aime bien aussi je suis
fan de la poularde moi une très belle
poularde pochée avec des légumes sauce
albufeira du foie gras des gens qu'on
aime noël est réussi alors le réveillon
noël coïncide souvent avec avec la
blonde ans de produits on a souvent les
yeux un petit peu plus gros que le
ventre on va pas se mentir tariq
la table est en général surchargé de mai
oui bien chargé c'est un peu la grande
bouffe généreux chaleureux généreux
disons généreux et tout ça se vérifie
bien sûr dans nos archives
on va prendre un exemple en 1958 et tout
commence comme un véritable conte de
fées avec une merveilleuse pyramide de
victuailles
nous allons reconnaître des crevettes
[Musique]
des volailles bien sûr des homards
encore vivants sangliers des bécasses
des grives
en somme tout ce qui constitue un buffet
et vous le savez un buffet c'est une
table à étagères plus ou moins grande où
sont disposées divers plats pour le
plaisir des yeux mais attention ces
images qu'on vient de voir elles n'ont
pas été prises dans un foyer on n'a pas
cette pyramide de victuailles
mais dans un restaurant parce que à
l'époque dans les années 50 la tradition
à noël elle était tout autre à table en
tout cas elle était toute autre
un spécialiste nous raconte tout ça en
1971 il organisait une exposition sur
les traditions de noël on va l'écouter
tout de suite la famille toute la maison
va se retrouver réunis dans une commande
ducation c'est à dire l'acte magique de
manger ensemble un repas mais grave
puisque nous sommes encore vigile de
noël qui sera constitué par les
productions essentiellement de la ferme
du mas et dont l'abondance en quelque
sorte sera le présage de la prospérité
de l'année nouvelle de la récolte
nouvelle c'est donc un repas joyeux mais
un repas symbolique la symbolique et
jean françois piège vous estimer qu'on
la retrouve encore dans ce repas de noël
aujourd'hui on peut la faire en cuisine
comment et bien sûr l'equilibre moi je
parlais poularde au lieu de la retire
peut-être on peut la push est comme ça
elle sera dans un bouillon peut-être
plus léger on peut trouver des symboles
la poularde et dans la ferme
le canard peut y être aussi été trouvés
dans le bouillon mais des légumes on va
apporter aussi une touche de légèreté et
de trouver des petites clés pour égayer
peut-être des produits qu'on aurait
peut-être trouvé sous d'autres formes et
les rendre festif annuel
moi c'est ce que j'aime c'est ce que je
vous ai dit vous avez par exemple un
produit qui n'existait pas au début de
votre carrière et qui aujourd'hui
apparaît peut-être plus comme un produit
de fête il devenu un produit de fait ces
dernières années les grands produits
sont l'appui de
toujours c'est pour ça que j'en ai fait
ce livre parce que c'est vrai que je les
enjeux l'organiser alphabétiquement par
l'origine des ingrédients
moi je dis pas des produits des
ingrédients c'est dans mon langage et il
ya des produits et des ingrédients qu'on
retrouve aujourd'hui peut-être un petit
peu plus fréquemment
c'était peut-être le végétal c'est vrai
qu'on mangeait plus de protéines avant
et un peu moins de végétal aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on est un petit peu plus
tourné vers vers le monde végétal
vous savez ces légumes qu'on avait dit à
oublier qu'ils sont revenus en force ya
quelques années moi je vous vois là tout
le ban et moi j'aime mes pensées les
avoir oubliées mais tient dans une
volaille quelques topinambours pocher
dépanner et puis au cas où si c'est noël
on peut mettre un peu de gaieté saint
jacques c'est excellent je suis dacc ou
devrais-je est d'accord je suis d'accord
le champagne s'était également fait
faire une place sur la table de noël
alors ça par contre tarik et pas
franchement une tradition si ancienne
que non moi je pensais que c'était ça se
faisait depuis la nuit des temps mais en
fait il était plutôt dans la tradition
on avait plutôt tendance à boire le vin
local le vin du coin on va voir ça avec
un exemple dans le beaujolais alors vous
doutez bien de ce qu'on voit là bas on
va en 1967 au réveillon dans le
beaujolais et les autres avaient même un
anime pour célébrer leur bain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bons petits vins du beaujolais et on le
répète quand il ya des supers 20 mai
dans sur et bien ceci même beaujolais
nouveau mais vous jean françois piège
vous buvez quoi la table de noël
alors moi je bois uniquement du vin
français je suis assez cocardier vous
avez vu j'ai fait un livre de cuisine
française et j'ai un amour fou pour les
viticulteurs des gens qui aiment alors
je bois les gens que j'aime en fête des
vignerons comme jean-louis chave
et il y en a d'autres c'est jean le chef
c'est l'ermitage saint joseph c'est un
vin qui est issu de ma région natale
cd20 que j'aime boire parce que c'est
des gens qui ont une responsabilité qui
est une connaissance de l'histoire de la
viticulture qui font des vins des lycées
jour le nation de votre votre réponse
aussi aussi eux aussi mais c'est ça
aussi la table c'est cette machine à
remonter le temps moi je dis la seule
machine visant à remonter le temps c'est
le vin parce que on peut boire un vin de
son année de naissance et et c'est assez
rare de pouvoir consommer un produit
vivant parce que le vin est vivant du
passé alors incontournable parmi les
incontournables de noël bien sûr la
bûche night la bûcherie et qui n'a pas
toujours été pâtissière vous le savez un
la bûche c'était bien sûr ce morceau de
bois qu'on jeté à la cheminée qu'on
pouvait faire brûler la nuit trois jours
douze jours un jour par mois de l'année
enfin ça dépend des traditions il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de traditions
différentes selon les régions où la
taille de la cheminée un wallaby bien
sûr et donc cette tradition elle était
aussi je vous disais symbole de
croyances on va voir un exemple dans le
berry
dans le berry un chêne est abattu à
minuit et le chef de famille rapporte à
la ferme une énorme poche la carte du
now qui devra brûlé pendant trois jours
dans le foyer sont piqués par la flamme
de noël
l'acoss ayant été béni par le maître du
logis puis par sa compagne les parcelles
de son écorce seront jetés sous les
meubles pour conjurer le mauvais oeil
voilà la bûche dans le berry en 50 2
comment est ce qu'elle est devenue
pâtissière commencé devenu commence à
passer d'un morceau de bois c'est que
c'est il ya une tradition il ya une
histoire mais c'est aussi l'inventivité
des pâtissiers qui ont oeuvré pour
transformer ce morceau de bois en gâteau
c'est le gâteau roulé en fait hein c'est
la version du gâteau roulé d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui on va même encore plus loin
parce qu'on lui donne d'autres formes à
la bûche
on essaye de les pâtissiers sont son
plein d'inventivité on envoie voilà bien
on parle du gâteau roulé on le voit
exactement là l'important c'est que ce
soit peu sucré et ça finit sur une
touche de légèreté parce que à noël on a
souvent plus manger un petit peu plus
riches donc c'est vrai que le rôle du
pâtissier important c'est de faire une
bûche très légère et très vives pour
qu'on garde cet cette fraîcheur pour
vivre un bon moment
j'aime beaucoup quand vous nous parler
de la bûche que vous et b1 parce qu'elle
se décline à l'infini
elle est même salle et chez vous jean
françois piège alors comment est ce qu
on en arrive à à dire tiens je vais
faire un matin je vais faire une bûche
salle est oui alors ça c'est des petits
jeux qu'on a de temps en temps on aime
bien s'approprier un univers dans d'un
autre c'est à dire du mon pâtissier et
un jour j'ai fait une bûche avec du foie
gras une bûche salé qui a permis même
avec du saumon fumé un avocat ou un
avocat aussi jeu mais j'en ai fait pas
mal on s'amuse en fait moi je trouve que
la cuisine c'est un terrain de jeu et on
s'amuse à faire plaisir
cuisiner c'est la volonté de faire
plaisir aux autres donc on tire quelques
ficelles parfois et on va dans le monde
sucré pour l'amener dans le monde salé
et vice et versa pas d'interdît non
niveau bûche mais attention à cette
grande bouffe qui peut peser lourd sur
l'estomac et surtout le lendemain le
lendemain avec la fameuse gueule de bois
alors je vous propose une dernière
archives avant qu'on se quitte
malheureusement pourrait parler
indéfiniment de nourriture avec vous
un conseil de rosie morel qui me donne
son remède anti gueule de bois en 1972
vous avez bien mangé hier trop margé est
trop bu et maintenant vous avez de la
tête lourde et la langue chargée et vous
vous demandez qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
et bien y avoir des petits remèdes qui
ne valent aiea le jus de choucroute le
crash a écrasée passe au dessus est ce
que le médicament classique qui consiste
à associer qui veut carbonate de soude
et d'aspirine et efficace et bien oui le
oui carbonate de soude ne fait pas
digérer parce que heureusement on a déjà
digéré mais augmente les sécrétions
acides de l'estomac et luttent contre
cette impression de bouche pâteuse
quant à l'aspirine et l'autre le mal de
tête et surtout surtout il faut boire de
l'eau beaucoup d'eau l'eau et le premier
est le meilleur des médicaments contre
ce qu'on appelle vulgairement la gueule
de bois
jean françois piège à quoi va ressembler
votre
24 décembre recevoir votre réveillon
qu'est ce qu'on mange chez vous en
famille en famille on va être on va être
mon épouse et mes enfants on va manger
probablement une volaille pocher comme
je vous dis une belle volée fauché avec
des légumes avec le bouillon avec le
bouillant je ferai une sauce parce que
je suis amoureux de cette sauce
albufeira lui fera c'est avec un peu de
foie gras
alors c'est avec du foie gras ou c'est
en sauce blanche avec du piment c'est il
ya les deux recettes dans le livre c'est
à choisir il ya la version escoffier la
version à la chapelle je suis un peu
plus alain chapel version programme
j'aimerais j'aimerais revenir quelques
instants sur la situation des
restaurants des des restaurateurs
certains de vos confrères ont décidé de
même s'ils ne peuvent plus accueillir de
clients de d'ouvrir leur cuisine et de
faire de la livraison à domicile on le
fait nous aussi un volet du click and
collect c'est comme ça quand c'est comme
ça qu'on dit je sais que vous le faites
est-ce que vous avez hésité avant de
vous lancer dans cette dans cette
opportunité
alors l'hésitation elle était de savoir
comment il fallait faire parce qu'on a
réappris un métier qui était pas de
notes c'est de pouvoir nous on produit
on donne aux clients à consommer il
fallait que le temps soit un petit peu
plus grand qu'on puisse réchauffer donc
on a travaillé pour essayer de faire
vivre aux clients la même expérience
chez eux que chez nous alors c'est pas
la même c'est au plus près donc il a
fallu un temps d'adaptation une fois
qu'on a eut trouvé ça il fallait mettre
en place les réseaux ça toutes les
équipes se sont affairés et oui on le
fait c'est difficile de transporter ses
deux étoiles jusque chez un particulier
alors nous on a fait le choix de palets
sur le terrain avec gastronomie on est
allé on a fait le choix de la cuisine
bourgeoise ce qu'on fait à la poule au
pot et au green c'est-à-dire set cette
semaine ya un pâté croûte
il ya un contre filet il ya une côte de
boeuf ya une poularde on fait des choses
comme ça en fait on cherche pas à faire
croire qu'on peut faire la même chose on
a choisi la cuisine qui pouvait
s'adapter
c'est ce qu'il fallait faire et on a
travaillé pour ça et et on met tout
notre coeur en tous les cas et merci de
nous faire partager votre passion
je rappelle le titre de votre livre la
cuisine française recettes bourgeoise et
populaire c'est chez hachette jean
françois piège deux étoiles merci à vous
et à très bientôt on va on va se quitter
bien sûr avec notre traditionnel pépite
un pas de noël sans chants de noël voici
amélie interprété par carlos joe dassin
jane manson et dave en 1977
croix des droits du gardé à vue
g
[Musique]
store
voilà on se retrouve dans trois semaines
début janvier à 21h sur le canal 27
d'ici là prenez soin de vous passer de
bonnes fêtes un grand merci à celles qui
nous ont aidés à préparer cette émission
anne delavaux et magali verdun
documentaliste de l'ina bonne soirée et
bonne fête
[Musique]